[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen liebe Zuschauer bei history
life dem historischen Quartett auf
Phönix Mohammed das Leben und das Wirken
des Propheten großes Thema seit
Jahrhunderten und gerade jetzt besonders
aktuell wir diskutieren das mit den
islamssen ler gutund grämer von der
Freien Universität Berlin mohannad K von
der Uni Münster und Abdel Hakim oge aus
Freiburg Herr og vor etwas über ein Jahr
haben wir hier in dieser Sendung
diskutiert über das Thema Jesus Mythos
und Wahrheit und heute machen wir
dasselbe die gleiche Frage Mohammed
Mythos und Wahrheit hat er denn
überhaupt
gelebt ja doch mohammed hat schon gelebt
und und zwar geboren
570 gestorben
632 wir haben historische Dokumente die
das belegen sowohl der Koran als
historisches Dokument in Form einer
Offenbarung wir haben auch die
sogenannte Tradition des Propheten
nämlich das sagen und das Handeln des
Propheten wir haben auch die sogenannten
biographische Werke über die wier des
Propheten aber wie sind diese Quellen me
es gibt ja erzunehmende Leute die das in
Frage stellen die historische Existenz
und diese Quellen sind ja erst zum Teil
Jahrzehnte Jahrhunderte nach dem Leben
von Mohammed standen also erstmal wir
haben der Koran das ist nämlich die
Offenbarung und da erfahren wir einiges
über das Leben des Propheten nämlich wir
erfahren z.B dass der Prophet ein
Verkünder einer Religion und zwar als
Mensch z.B die Sure 1810 dass Mohammed
nur ein Mensch war wir haben die
sogenannte Biografien des Propheten die
sind entstanden zwei Jahrhunderte nach
dem Tod des Propheten und da haben wir
eher mit einer Verfremdung von
historischen Taten nämlich wir können
hier unterscheiden zwischen zwei
Begriffe nämlich Mohammed als Verkünder
einer Religion und nach zwei
Jahrhunderten wir haben Mohammed als ein
verkündeten nämlich dass die Muslime ihn
verkündet haben durch seine Taten und
sein Handeln halt die Frage wie geht man
nämlich mit diesen Biografien und wie
geht mal mit diesen nämlich die
Tradition des Propheten inzwischen in
der islamischen Welt wird die Tradition
des Propheten in Zweifel gezogen nämlich
es handelt sich um eine
Manipulation der der der Tradition des
Propheten die sogenannte Sunna als
religiösen Text und zwar zu
ideologischen Gründen oder Zwecken das
klingt nicht sehr nach der kritischen
historischen Methode gibt es denn
irgendwelche wirklich handfesten
historischen Beweise Belege Quellen für
die Existenz von Mohammed Frau Krämer
also ich halte ihn für eine historische
Figur in der Tat und
m was inzwischen von einer kritischen
Wissenschaft nur noch in Teilen Frage
gestellt wird ist dass der Koran als
offenbarungsschrift tatsächlich in die
Zeit datiert in der Mohammad nach
muslimischer Überzeugung gelebt hat
neueste Untersuchungen an einzelnen
Fragmenten des Korans deuten darauf hin
dass er tatsächlich dass diese Fragmente
tatsächlich im zweiten Drittel des
siebten Jahrhunderts entstanden sind und
das ist schon mal ein wichtiges
puzzelstückchen die Überlieferungen über
das Leben des Propheten Mohammed sind
tatsächlich viel späterer Zeit ich würde
sie nicht als Augenzeugen Berichte
werden und auch nicht als unangreifbare
historische Quelle sondern als
Glaubenszeugnis und dann verweist die
Wissenschaft und zwar die kritische auf
bestimmte Hinweise in nichttislamischen
Quellen syrische Mönche armenische
Mönche und andere die zumindest davon
zeugen dass auf der arabischen Halbinsel
Unruhe entstand arabische Eroberung
stattfanden die sind unbestritten und es
gibt auch Hinweise auf eine Figur
Mohammad
aber die sagen uns natürlich nicht genau
wer dieser Mann war und ob das nun ein
Titel oder eine Person ist dennoch denke
ich insgesamt gibt es genug Zeugnis die
es plausibel erscheinen lassen dass es
diese Figur gegeben hat und dass er eine
religiöse Strömung gestaltet hat ich
lasse es vielleicht mal dabei ja was
heißt das für Sie Herr kchit ist das
alles historisch relevant oder ist das
doch eine Überhöhung die in den
Jahrzehnten Jahrhunderten darauf dann um
ihn und mit ihm geschehen ist zuerst
grundsätzlich wir haben
ter papirus W das ist ein Gefährte der
Gefährten des Propheten wo eine
Erwähnung Mohammeds im Jahre 732 schon
zu finden ist das hat Professor Schöler
dokumentiert wir haben eben wie sie
erwähnt haben auch in nichttislamischen
Quellen der historische oder der
psantinische Historiker
Theo mfes der äh 832 ihn schon erwähnt
hat wir haben da und dort in den Quellen
islamische wie nicht islamische Quellen
eine Erwähnung von Mohammed allerdings
wie sie gesagt haben m die Quellen auf
die wir uns heute
Berufen eben Ishak also der erste
wirklich der erste Biografie die
systematisch
gesammelt wurde niedergeschrieben wurde
die uns erreicht hat nicht direkt von
eben Ishak sondern von einem Schüler
seines Schülers eben Ishak selbst 707 67
gestorben Mohammed
632 und dieser Schüler des Schülers eben
Hisham ist
833 gestorben das heißt wir das Material
was wir haben ist in der Tat 150 bis 200
Jahre nach dem Tod des Propheten
niedergeschrieben wurde weil eben Hisham
das was eben Ishak gesammelt hat
revidiert hat und eben Ishak selbst ist
eine umstrittene Person in der
islamischen Tradition auch also das
kommt auch noch dazu aber was wichtig
ist sind nicht die historischen Fakten
an sich also über den historischen
Mohammed wir wissen dass er es ihn
gegeben hat aber wir wissen sehr wenig
auch wann er wirklich geboren ist in der
Wissenschaft wissen wir auch nicht genau
da gibt es wieder strebende Quellen die
einen sagen 550 die anderen 570 aber
wenn die Eroberung von Mekka 610
stattgefunden hat dann wäre er ja nach
der einenthe schon 60 Jahre alt geworden
kaum vorstellbar
oder genau genau wissten wir nicht äh
also wann wirklich also diese
historischen Details da wissen wir
ziemlich wenig über den Prophet Mohammed
aber sie haben mich
und und das glaube ich eher was relevant
ist was sie gefragt haben bezogen auf äh
die religiöse relevant für die Muslime
für die Gläubigen der Koran selbst
erwähnt z.B mehr aus dem Leben Moses als
aus dem Leben Mohammed oder aus dem
Leben Jesus als aus dem Leben Mohammed
also da finden wir viel mehr Details
über moses Jesus im Koran als über
Mohammed also offensichtlich ist für den
Glauben selbst die die historischen
Details nicht so relevant wie das
Wirkens Mohammed seine Botschaft der
Koran selbst als Verkündigung das ist
das was für uns Gläubige auch für die
islamische Theologie relevant ist und
weniger die
historischen Fakten um Mohammed selbst
aber wir sind ja nun mal eine
historische Sendung und deswegen frage
ich kann man den den Koran reinen
Herzens auch als historische Quelle
bewerten oder muss man ihn als eher
religiöse Quelle mit all den
Einschränkungen anschauen Frau krer ich
würde ihn nicht als historische Quelle
in dem Sinne werten dass er uns
Aufschluss gibt über das Handeln
Mohammads
auf täglicher Basis sozusagen das ist
auch soweit ich das erkennen kann
überhaupt nicht die Funktion dieser
Schrift äh wichtig ist er doch insofern
also nun mal das zentrale Dokument ist
das davon zeugt dass in dem Raum von dem
wir sprechen westlicher Teil der
arabischen Halbinsel in dem Zeitraum an
den wir
denken auf jeden Fall erstes Drittel des
7 jahrhunderts ein religiöses Dokument
entstand an dessen Existenz man nicht
zweifeln kann und das jetzt sogar mit
naturwissenschaftlichen Methoden
jedenfalls in einzelnen Fragmenten noch
genauer datiert werden kann als zuvor
also die Existenz des Koran für sich
genommen ist schon mal wichtig auch als
historisches Faktum nur würde ich ihn da
wier wiederhole ich mich ein wenig würde
ich ihn nicht dazu benutzen n
herausfinden zu wollen wie Mohammad im
Einzelnen gelebt hat dafür gibt es
andere Quellen und die haben auch eine
andere Funktion profitiert der
islamische Glaube denn von der
historischen Quellen Unsicherheit
bezüglich der wiitaer des Propheten Herr
ugi na ja es es ist vielleicht oder ich
würde so sagen nämlich W Muslime
besonders die gläub sind nämlich dass
diese historischen authentisch gelten
und für uns Wissenschaftler wir gehen
eher kritisch damit um für mich das
allerwichtigste das muss ich auch genau
Beter betonen wir haben deutliche und
sogar ausführliche Hinweise in dem
Korantext über der einzelne Momente
historische Momente über das Leben des
Propheten das ist das wichtigste und
darüber hinaus der Koran als ein
kanonische Quelle es ist sage ich mal
für uns nämlich das sind nicht nur
religiöse Berichte sondern auch was ich
vorhin erwähnt habe diese wie der
Mohammed gelebt hat wir haben zum was
wir in dem Koran entdecken nämlich
Mohammed als Mensch das ist sehr wichtig
weil das Vorbild des Propheten im Laufe
der Jahrhunderte W wurde dogmatisiert
sogar wurde zu einem Mythos mit also zu
einem Mythos nämlich wie haben einen
Propheten der so oft in dem Koran
kritisiert wird in der Sure 80 Vers 1
bis 10 Gott kritisiert Mohammed also z.B
der Umgang des Propheten mit seinen
Ehefrauen da wird auch Mohammed
kritisiert oder z.B Gott sagte zu
Mohammed das ist nicht die deine Aufgabe
die Menschen zu bekehren sondern einfach
die Botschaft zu verkünden also was ist
denn die Frage beim Umgang von Mohammed
mit seinen Ehefrauen wenn wir schon
dabei sind wenn sie das jetzt schon
ansprechen her
i na ja also meinen sie über mit seinen
Frauen ja so wie sie es gesagt haben ja
es es es ist also die Frauen das Frau
Thea ist es schon was anders als wenn
wir jetzt über den historischen Mohammed
sprechen das eine gehört ja zum anderen
dazu wenn es einen historischen Mohammed
gegeben hat dann ist die Geschichte mit
den Frauen ja auch existent also wenn es
um Frauen im Islam geht wir müssen
unterscheiden nämlich zwischen die
koranischen Stellen wo Frauen erwähnt
werden z.B dass die Männer ein Stufe
höher als die Frauen stehen oder nämlich
dass die Frauen be bei Erbschaft einfach
die Hälfte kriegen oder bei jistischen
die Frau als Zeugin darf also ihre
Stimme zählt zur Hälfte also das sind
solche sage ich mal Verse die müssen wir
unbedingt in ihrem historischen Kontext
verstehen und wir sagen ganz deutlich
dass Sie zu unserer Zeit nicht passen
wir haben auch einige Aussagen des
Propheten wo die Frau sage ich mal jao
die Tradition des Propheten kein tolles
Bild über Frauen vermittelt wird und ich
gehe mal davon aus was ich auch immer
gesagt habe es handelt sich um eine
Verfremdung nämlich des Handelns und des
sagen des Propheten halt wie
grundsätzlich kritisch wie grundsätzlich
in frageestellend darf denn ein amtlich
bestellter bestalter
Islamwissenschaftler einer deutschen
Hochschule in Sachen Mohammeds wirken
und seiner Zeit sein ich meine wie
gesagt die Quellenlage ist so dünn dass
wir nicht anders können als kritisch mit
diesen Quellen äh umgehen das hat die
islamische Tradition schon gemacht wie
gesagt also eben Ishak selbst über ihn
wurde von niemand geringeren als von
Imam Malik das ist der Begründer ein der
vier Rechtschulen im sunnitischen Islam
Imam Malik hat ihm bezeichnet als Lügner
einfach also also so kritisch war das
eigentlich und das ist unsere
Hauptquelle über das Leben des
historischen Mohammeds und in diesen
Quellen die wir haben wir haben auch
sehr viel Widersprüchliches drinnen was
aber wichtig ist und relevant ist ist
das was in islamisch rezppiert wird
inner islamisch wird oder wurde über
viele Jahrhunderte nicht eben Ishak
nicht eben hisam rezppiert sondern
völlig andere Bücher die später
entstanden sind also im ganz türkischen
Bereich ist ein Buch der aus dem 12
Jahrhundert das aus dem 12 Jahrhundert
stammt Kitab schifa schifa
von dass das Wirken Mohammeds beschreibt
das wurde über Jahrhunderte rezppiert
oder später sind das nicht Überhöhungen
sind das nicht Überhöhungen
myologisierungen das sind eher
gefilterte also das sind nicht diese
typischen
kriegschroniken wie bei eben Ishak oder
hisam zu finden oder später im 15
jahrhundertirat ein Buch das starke
Verbreitung in der
innerislamischen im volksislam aber auch
in der innerislamischen Tradition gibt
wo es nicht um die Figur Mohammeds als
kriegsher geht sondern eben um eher die
Vorzüge Mohammed als barmherzigen
Propheten und das das ist das was sich
sehr stark durchgesetzt hat diese
Rezeptionsgeschichte und deshalb wenn
Muslime heute wenn Sie negatives hören
vom Propheten auch über Dinge die bei
eben Ishak oder da oder dort in den
Quellen stehen ist sofort eine
Abwehrreaktion sag Moment das ist nicht
mein Prophet also die Geschichte
Mohammeds die im volksislam rezipiert
wird ist eine andere als ein Kriegsherr
wie sonst in in in den Islam kritischen
Quellen zu finden ist und ich glaube das
ist wichtig Rezeptionsgeschichte
Mohammeds eben Ishak neigte dazu viel zu
glorifizieren in seinem kriegschroniken
und möglichst Mohammed als kriegsherrde
möglichst viele Kriege gewonnen hat
möglichst viele Menschen umgebracht
haben haben wir sehr viel
Widersprüchliches an Material aber was
wichtig ist ist nicht das sondern
wichtig ist was inner islamisch
rezppiert wurde und was sich
letztendlich durchgesetzt hat und wir
haben hier einen Unterschied zwischen
Koran und Bibel ich wollte nur einen
Satz zu vgen Frage äh sagen in der Bibel
finden wir wir viele Fakten also Namen
von Personen Daten Orte das finden wir
kaum im Koran so Daten überhaupt nicht
eigentlich Namen von Personen kaum Orte
kaum Orte die Vorkommen im Koran es ist
offensichtlich das Anlegen des Korans
ist eben nicht historische Fakten zu
liefern sondern das vorhandene narrativ
auf der arabischen Halbinsel äh zu
eren mit einem Inhalt mit einem Glaubens
Inhalt und nicht die Aufgabe jetzt ich
sage euch wer wann wo gelebt hat
und also welche historischen Umstände
damals waren sondern er möchte eine
Botschaft eine religiöse Botschaft hier
Transp ich würde wenn sie mir erlauben
hier was
hinzufügen und zwar nämlich diese
biographischen oder diese Werke über die
wier des Propheten vermitteln uns ein
kein neutrales Bild aber wir haben auch
gleich seitig nämlich in dem Korantext
der offenbart von 610 bis
622 der sogenannte mekanische Koran wir
entdecken hier ein Propheten nämlich als
Verkünder eines sage ich mal ein
ethischen eine ein ein sinnstiftende
ethische Religion wir haben ab
622 bis
632 bis zu dem Tod des Propheten nämlich
ein nicht nur ein ein Verkünder ein der
Religion SN wir haben hier auch ein ein
Staatsmann nämlich wir lesen in dem
Koran Hinweise wie der welche Kriege der
Prophet gefört hat nämlich also die die
Kriege gegen die damaligen arabischen
paganen oder gegen die Kriege gegen die
Juden wie haben Verse die da darauf
hinweisen deutlich nämlich dass Mohammed
auch ein ein ein Politiker war das ist
das ist gut da reden wir doch mal drüber
reden wir doch jetzt mal über den
Propheten über Mohammed in der Zeit in
der er gelebt hat in welche politischen
und geographischen Verhältnisse wurde
denn überhaupt hineingeboren wie sah
seine Lebenswirklichkeit aus das weiß ja
kaum jemand unserer Zuhörer ja wir
können es zum Teil aber auch nur
wiederum aus Quellen erschließen die
später sind oder oder auch früher weil
wir uns ein Bild von der Gesellschaft
dieser Zeit und dieses Raums machen das
nicht durch zeitgenössische Quellen
jetzt mit ethnographischer oder
historiographischer Präzision
dargestellt
wird um eines noch
vorauszuschicken all die Versuche
historisch einzuordnen basieren darauf
dass wir wissen haben müssen über die
Zeit und den Hintergrund das aber auch
wieder in Frage gestellt werden kann
also soweit wir das rekonstruieren
können ist es so dass die arabische
Halbinsel eingebettet war in größere
politische Zusammenhänge die im
Wesentlichen durch die zwei Großmächte
dieser Zeit bestimmt wurden das war das
Byzantinische Reich Schwerpunkt
Konstantinopel das auch ein großen Teil
des syrischen nordafrikanischen Raums
beherrschte also Ägypten z.B der
syrische Raum heutiges Israel Palästina
Libanon Jordanien und Syrien selber und
für bestimmte Zeite Zeiten auch den
heutigen Irak und konkurrieren damit das
sassanidische Reich dass wir häufig
persisch nennen dessen Hauptstadt aber
im heutigen Irak lag also kein einfach
persisches reich sondern auch schon über
regional
überthnisch äh dass diesen selben Raum
auch beanspruchte und zwischendurch äh
für eine bestimmte Zeit auch beherrschte
nun waren die Sasaniden auch entlang der
Küsten der arabischen Halbinsel präsent
Ostküste heutige Emirate Oman und so
weiter bis hin in den heutigen jemmen
und dann gibt es noch eine Macht die man
nennen muss nämlich das christliche
Äthiopien auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent wie nun diese Mächte im
einzelnen nach meckka und Medina wirkten
also die Orte um die es wesentlich geht
ist gar nicht so leicht zu erschließen
es scheint auf jeden Fall
Handelskontakte gegeben zu haben ich
glaube schon dass man davon ausgehen
kann dass Mohammad im Handel tätig war
wobei alte Vorstellung dass hier der die
Weihrauchstraße durch mecka noch
gelaufen sei überholt sind die
beirrauchstraße funktionierte im 7
Jahrhundert schon nicht mehr und und
mecka war wohl eher in einen etwas
bescheidenen Handel eingebunden aber
immerhin hat der Handel Außenkontakte
vermittelt auch ein Wissen von der Welt
das über meckka und Medina
hinausreichte und schließlich ist noch
ganz wichtig dass christliche und
jüdische Gemeinschaften auf der
arabischen Halbinsel selbst lebten ob
genau zur selben Zeit am selben Ort ist
nicht so ganz klar zu eroieren Juden auf
jeden Fall in
Medina und wir können darauf glaube ich
auch deswegen schließen weil ja der
Koran den wir nun doch ganz überwiegend
als historisches Dokument wenn auch
nicht historische
Beschreibung werden so viele biblische
Geschichten enthält und das finde ich
die Sache die man wirklich sich mal
überlegen muss wie kann es sein dass die
Bewohner von meckka und Medina die ja
nun überwiegend weder Juden noch
Christen waren sofort wussten was es mit
Maria und mit Josef auf sich hat und was
Jona im Bauch des Wahs gemacht hat das
wird im Koran nur so ansatzweise
angesprochen und ihr wisst doch Jona im
wah und so weiter also müssen wir davon
aus dass diese Erzählungen präsent waren
und in diesem Sinne es einerseits diese
machtpolitische großszene gab und dann
eine kulturelle Szene und dann Kontakte
über Handel und wahrscheinlich auch über
Familien und über die Dichtung die
arabische Dichtung als ein ganz
interessantes Gewebe Gespinst Geflecht
das wir im einzelnen noch nicht so genau
entwirren können und in dieser
Wirklichkeit wurden ja Kriege geführt
von Mohammed waren das dann Verteidigung
Kriege wie manche behaupten oder schon
regelrechte
Eroberungskriege zum Zwecke der
Missionierung für einen neuen Glauben je
nach Rezeption es gibt innerislamisch
Quellen die das so rezipieren und andere
die anders wie rezepieren äh also für
mich ist es sehr wichtig mich sehr stark
für das eine narrativ zu machen dass es
hier um reine Verteidigungs Kämpfe
ergangen ist äh das lese ich als
gläubigen Menschen im Koran also die
Stellen auch die äh zwei sure 191 192
man rekrutiert immer wieder darauf als
es dort heißt tötet sie wo immer ihr sie
findet aber wenn ich das im Zusammenhang
lese der Vers davor 190 da heißt es
also führt Krieg gegen diejenigen die
euch bekriegen also das ist ganz klar im
Text worum es geht eigentlich um kann
man mit verteidigungskriegen zu dieser
Expansion des Islam kommen der ja in den
kommenden Jahrzehnten dann stattgefunden
hat bisch nach Spanien was nachher
gekommen ist war definitiv keine
verteidigungskriege also nach der Zeit
des Propheten das wussten auch übrigens
die Kalifen selbst also wir haben ja
inner islamisch das starke narrativ dass
ein späterer Kalif umarn Abdulasis der
später gekommen ist umadische Kalif als
erste
Handlung die er durchgeführt hat als
Kalif geworden ist hatte
alle Soldaten die ganze Armee zurück
gezogen zurückgerufen und hat er gesagt
es geht hier nicht wirklich um äh
glauben es geht nicht um Islam sondern
rein um Expansion um Macht und das will
ich nicht das widerspricht meinem
verstehnis vom Islam deshalb wird er als
das als der fünfte Kalif bezeichnet in
der islamische war nicht der fünfte aber
äh sozusagen der rechtschaffene fünfte
Kalif weil er es ja ehrlich gemeint hab
aber wir haben natürlich omayadische
aber südische Dynastie äh viele
Beispiele von expansionskriege wo es
wirklich um Macht ergangen ist und nicht
um den Glauben und schon gar nicht um
Verteidigung das muss man ganz klar
sagen
also ja also hier hätte ich eine andere
Sicht zugegebenermaßen eine Sicht von
außen zugegebenermaßen die Sicht der
Historikerin die mit dieser Ungewissheit
leben muss ich stelle es mir so vor dass
Mohammad und seine Anhänger davon
ausgingen dass Sie die richtige Religion
haben die richtige Religion die ihnen
Gott aufgetragen hat zu
verbreiten und ob da nun Verteidigung im
strengen Sinne im Spiel war oder einfach
die Auffassung mit der Wahrheit zu sein
und diese Wahrheit den Menschen auch
bringen zu
sollen kann ich natürlich nicht streng
entscheiden aber mir leuchtet das mehr
einzusagen dass diese Überzeugung da war
jedenfalls auf der Seite Mohammads und
sein engeren Anhänger und ihnen haben
sich viele Leute angeschlossen denke ich
die nicht in erster Linie nachgedacht
haben wie das nun religiös alles zu
sehen sondern die hier auch den Sog des
Erfolgs und des Gewinns und des auch des
Ansehens gespürt haben also ich gehe
nicht von reinen verteidigungspfgen aus
sondern von einer ungewissen Lage wo
sehr schnell auch derjenige der sich
kritisch oder skeptisch geäußert hat als
Feind gesehen und bekämpft wurde und die
Frage ist nun da gehen wir aber schon in
die Moderne Rezeption hinein die ihn so
am Herzen liegt wie heutige mus damit
umgehen ob sie diese reine Verteidigung
in den Vordergrund ste stellen oder ob
sie sagen das war eine historische
Situation die folgte ihren eigenen
Gesetzen Gesetzen des 7 jahrhunderts wir
sind im 21 Jahrhundert wir folgen
anderen
Gesichtspunkten dann Herr Kid klingt für
mich plausibel für Sie auch Herr nein
also ich respektiere die Meinung von
Herrn koschid aber also mohammed hat
nicht nur verteidigungskriege geführt
das ist auch dokumentiert in dem Koran
nämlich die Sure
929 also dass der Prophet einfach alle
bekämpft und genau hier entdecken wir
einen Begriff die Leute der Schrift halt
nämlich dass sie nicht verbieten was
Gott verboten hat oder dass sie nicht
erlauben oder in dieser Hinsicht halt
also der Prophet hat sage ich mal nicht
sich nicht nur verteidigt sondern auch
Kriege geförhrt nämlich mit dem Ziel
andere zu der sogenannten wahren
Religion zu beehren halt wir lesen auch
in dem Koran nämlich in ein suree ihr
seid die beste Gemeinschaft die nämlich
von Gott gestiftet worden ist also wir
müssen wirklich einfach die Sachen so
darstellen und unsere Muslimen auch
vermitteln wie sie sind es hilft uns
nicht irgendein Bild über den Propheten
zu vermitteln die den historischen
Tatsachen einfach nicht entsprechen halt
mohammed hat Kriege geführt Mohammed
hatte auch vor Menschen zu bekehren also
wir haben also das heißt was der
Mohammed in dieser medinensischen Zeit
von 622 bis 632 geführt hat wurde
fortgesetzt und zwar von seinen
Nachfolger später durch diese
Expansionen und Expansionen sage ich mal
da sind nicht man geht nicht und bekehrt
Menschen halt sondern es geht um Kriege
halt das ist das das allerwichtigste und
das interessante bei der ganzen
Geschichte das heutige sage ich mal die
sogenannten Extremisten dass sie sich
nach diesem Koran koranischen Stellen in
der medinensischen Zeit einfach nämlich
orientieren darüber hinaus ind der
Überzeugung wie seot oder benutia 1328
gestorben nämlich dass diese Koranverse
in der medinens sichchen Zeit abrogieren
bzwheben den mechanischen Koran auf
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen dass wir
unsere Zuhörern nicht überfordern das
war jetzt doch ein bisschen viel aber
Sie können auch sie wollten auch auf
Frau Krämer noch Antworten vi beide
gleich und da habe ich Rückfragen auch
an beide
der erste Vers im Koran oder anders wie
ich mein weil es ist immer die Frage für
welche Position man sich stark macht
also wir haben in der is also im
sunnitischen Islam die vier rechtchul
drei davon die hanfitische hambalitische
malikitische die sagen Jihad ist nur für
verteidigungszwecke erlaubt nur die
schafiitische sagt nein das ist Angriff
weil es um die Wahrheit geht um
Verbreitung des Islams das heißt
man darf genauso wenig auch den
Zuschauern und den Muslimen auch nicht
verschweigen dass der absolute Mehrheit
dreiviertel der sunnitischen Schulen
zumindest eine andere Meinung sind und
sagen nein es geht um Verteidigung und
sich dafür stark machen das muss man
erst einmal festhalten zweitens
Rückfragen aus dem Koran selbst der
erste
sure oder Vers überhaupt der Muslimen
erlaubt hat sich kriegerisch zu
betätigen 22 sure Vers 38 bis 40 der
heißt es dort äh den diejenigen die
bekämpft wurden ist Ihnen erlaubt zu
kämpfen weil ihen Unrecht getan wurden
weil sie aus ihren Häusern vertrieben
wurden es wird also dort
ähm also beschrieben worum es eigentlich
geht wie geht man damit um wie geht man
mit den vielen Stellen um im Koran die
Schutzgeld verlangen damit das der Krieg
aufhört nicht die Bekehrung es geht
nicht um die Wahrheit das ist jetzt ein
einziges Beispiel es in der Tat ein
einziger Vers im Koran in der neunten
sure die spätere Exegeten als der
schwertf dann genannt haben nicht alle
übrigens eben wenn sie erwähnt haben
Iben lesen Sie nach der sagt Jihad ist
reine Verteidigung nicht and das wir ja
heute noch von den verfächtern des Jihad
wir anders wird anders rezppiert also
von den Verfechtern des Jihads wird
rezppiert es geht um Wahrheit es geht um
und also nicht Muslime zu bekriegen weil
sie nicht Muslime sind nicht für das was
sie getan haben sondern für das was sie
sind bekriegen wir sie aber das ist eine
minderheitenpition innerhalb der
islamischen Tradition jeder sich aus dem
Koran das herausholen kann was ihm
gerade sozusagen passt eigentlich nicht
das ist der Aufgabe der koranischen
hermenoute Kriterien zu stellen damit
ist keine Beliebigkeit weder auf der
einen noch auf der anderen Seite noch
diejenigen die nur das Positive
herauspicken noch die jenigen die das
Negative wir kennen das übrigens aus der
Bibel genauso wir haben in der Bibel
genau solche und solche Stellen was
macht man in der Bibel man orientiert
sich an ein Kriterium klar und man
orientiert sich an einem Kriterium Jesus
und man sagt Jesus ist eine Botschaft
der Liebe W nehmen die Verse wo es um
die Liebe geht ähnliches kann man
genauso mache ich auch in einer
Theologie koranische Theologie der
Barmherzigkeit wo ist der Kriterium der
Barmherzigkeit alles was dem nicht
entspricht muss man im historischen
Kontext auch ne sure 29 verordnen die
letzte sure übrigens dem Koran verkündet
ist die fünfte sure die fünfte sure ist
eine ganz friedliche sure gegenüber auch
nicht mususlim gut nun hat ja trotz
allesdem nun hat ja trotz all dem die
Pakistan Autorin sabatina James vor
einiger Zeit ein Buch veröffentlicht
indem sie mit Mohammad hart ins Gericht
geht sie wirft ihm vor er habe Gewalt
gelehrt und ausgeübt was halten Sie von
dieser These Frau Krämer also ich bin
der Auffassung dass Mohammad und seine
Anhänger in der Tat auch Gewalt ausgeübt
haben auch Gewalt ich sehe sie nicht als
fanatische Kämpfer die nur mit Feuer und
Schwert den Islam itet haben aber so
eindeutig ist es nicht getrennt und das
gibt ja nun in der muslimischen
Tradition wir stützen uns ja auf die
muslimische Tradition wir haben ja
nichts anderes in der muslimischen
Tradition eine ganze Reihe von Hinweisen
denen zu entnehmen ist dass auch Gewalt
angewandt wurde also das Wort und auch
das Schwert ich halte nichts von diesen
modernen Abrechnungen bzw ich sehe sie
nicht als Auseinandersetzungen über den
historischen Mohammad oder die früher
Gemeinde sondern als Auseinandersetzung
darüber wie man heute als Muslim oder
als Muslim seine Religion lebt und ähm
man kann sich da nun nicht mit jeder
Abrechnung
endlos beschäftigen zum Teil ist das
auch nicht auf besonders viel Wissen
gebaut ähm aber über die Frage ob nun
Mohammad rein friedlich oder rein
gewaltw gewaltorientiert war gibt es
eine alte Auseinandersetzung ich halte
weder das eine noch das andere für äh
stichhaltig und bewege mich hier auch
auf einer gut islamischen Position die
ja die mittlere Position die das
Ausgleichs sehr würdigt nicht immer ist
das historisch richtig was in der Mitte
ist aber ich glaube hier tut man sich am
leichtesten wenn man auch so diese
Widersprüchlichkeit der Entwicklung sich
vor Augen führt und vielleicht immer
wieder fragt was waren denn die Maximen
gesellschaftlichen politischen Handelns
im 7 jahrhundert soweit wir das
erschließen können und die unterscheiden
sich nun mal gravierend von unserer
eigenen Gegenwart ist es nicht von der
Lebenswirklichkeit hier auch ganz
plausibel Herr dass jahrhundert ein
Staatsmann ein Religionsstifter auch
Gewalt ausüben musste ja also wie ich
vorhin erwähnt habe nämlich dieses
Handeln des Propheten sowohl religiöses
als auch politisches muss man in der
damaligen Situation einfach verstehen in
damaligen oder in der historischen
Kontext verstehen das ist aber zu wenig
es geht darum auch nämlich was welche
Lehren wir daraus ziehen für den
heutigen Islam das ist ihre Frage und
wenn sie mir erlauben möchte ich Frau
Kremmer auch was sagen und zwar also ich
bin eine andere Meinung für diese
Islamkritiker und zwar ich begrüße
solche Stimmen und zwar es ist uns es
ist unsere Aufgabe nämlich Muslime
einfach eine innerislamischen Debatte zu
etablieren besonders im im im westlichen
Kontext also hed abd Samad oder die die
sabtiner oder dieses Buch Halt gibt da
noch Nachholbedarf in der
innerislamischen Debatte ja viel also
wir sind ganz am Anfang es ist unsere
Aufgabe nämlich ein ein ein ein ein
Islamkritik im Rahmen einer
Aufklärungsprogramm hier bei uns im
Westen zu etablieren das heißt wenn man
den Propheten kritisiert oder den Koran
kritisiert darf man keine Angst haben
sondern es ist einfach eine Aufgabe
nämlich von uns Muslime einfach die
anderen Stimmen wahrzunehmen es mus
momentan Angst haben wenn man das so
grundsätzlich kritisiert muss man da
noch Angst haben als ja also ich glaube
schon also ich habe Kollegen die sage
ich mal wie der und der Polizeischutz
lebt weil er den Propheten kritisiert in
seinem letzten Buch da reden wir gerade
drüber also das Buch Mohammed eine
Abrechnung ind dem der Autor ihn als
Terroristen sogar bezeichn mir geht es
bitte wenn Sie erlauben mir geht's nur
darum dass wir wirklich den Mut haben
einfach den Islam zu kritisieren als ein
Liebeserklärung für die Muslime das ist
sehr wichtig es geht uns um eine um eine
Rezeption der des historischen Propheten
und von von den Koran nämlich gemäß der
jetzigen Situation es geht nicht nur
einfach die Quellen einfach so
anzunehmen und zu vermitteln als wir in
einer sage ich mal ein urklassische
Koranschule sind wir leben im Westen in
Berührung mit dem anderen sowohl mit
Christen und Juden und es ist unsere
Aufgabe von anderen zu lernen und auch
versuchen ein aufgeklärten Islam hier
bei uns zu etablieren und ein Islam der
sich reformieren lässt weil ein Islam
sage ich mal ganz deutlich der sich
nicht kritisieren lässt oder ein Islam
ohne einen Islamkritik es ist zum
Scheitern verurteilt hier bei uns in
Deutschland muss der Autor Abel Sammer
deswegen auch unter polizeischutzleben
wie er sagt weil es eben noch keinen
flächendeckenden aufgeklärten Islam gibt
ja auf jeden Fall also in seinem Fall da
wollen wir uns glaube ich jetzt nicht so
sehr reinvertiefen scheint es auch noch
das eine oder andere Motiv zu geben wir
würden uns doch hier nicht darüber
streiten dass es Islamkritik geben muss
eine ernstzunehmende Auseinandersetzung
und dass die in der Öffentlichkeit in
der islamischen Welt möglich sein muss
darin liegt ja das Problem dass man in
Ägypten heutzutage viele Sachen nicht
sagen kann die man vielleicht in
Indonesien aussprechen kann oder sogar
in Iran aber nicht in Ägypten oder in
Syrien ähm was mich ärgert ist dass die
stimmen die nun gerade nicht besonders
subtil sind und auch nicht von tiefer
Kenntnis geprägt hier mit einer
begierigkeit aufgegriffen und regelrecht
zelebriert wird die mir unheimlich ist
ich würde lieber kritische Stimmen sehen
die z.B generell diese positive
Bewertung der islamischen
Eroberungen betrachten wie kann es sein
dass Muslime heute ohne mit der Wimper
zu zucken uns erklären die Eroberungen
sein ein zivilisierungswerk gewesen mit
dem Ungläubige ins Licht des rechten
Glaubens gebracht
wurden hab chisten gesagt und das ist
ein klassisch kolonialer Diskurs genauso
sind die Engländer und die Franzosen
aufgetreten haben gesagt wir bringen
euch wir haben die Bürde des weißen
Mannes auf uns genommen wir bringen euch
das Licht der Zivilisation und das ist
gewissermaßen eine Erwiderung darauf
nein lautet dann das Argument vieler
Muslime es ist der Islam der das Licht
des der Zivilisation gebracht hat zu
einer Zeit der Finsternis das sind ja
ganz gebräuchliche Bilder ich würde das
gerne kritisch beleuchtet sehen ich
würde gerne tatsächlich eine kritische
Auseinandersetzung mit wesentlichen
Annahmen und auch der Figur Mohammad wie
sie konstruiert wurde sehen aber ich bin
unglücklich über diese Schriften die
hier so sehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt
werden und die ich nicht für hinreichend
seriös halte das ist natürlich ein
wissenschaftliches Hoffen und Bangen
aber ich mache ja auch dieses Fach weil
ich mich ernsthaft dafür interessiere
und wie gesagt ich hätte gerne ein paar
Schriften aus anderer Feder hier sitzen
ja Leute die das können also den Herr
warum ist es denn so dass dieser Prozess
der Aufklärung das wurde eben ja
angesprochen offenkundig flächendenken
noch vor uns steht was fehlt denn noch
um in diesen kritischen Prozess der
Durchdringung einzutreten ich glaube wir
sind mitten drinnen gerade es hat sehr
viel wach gerüttelt in der islamischen
Welt es finden sehr viele Kongresse
Konferenzen innerhalb der islamischen
den islamischen Ländern auch dort wo man
nur wie Länder in Saudi-Arabien eher ein
konservatives Bild vom Islam erwartet wo
dort jetzt seit d vi Jahren
sehr viel kritisiert wird an eigenen
Entwicklungen auch im theologischen
Diskurs als das sind Entwicklungen die
neu sind die wir so vor 10 Jahren noch
nicht erwartet hätten das heißt es tut
sich jetzt etwas und da müssen wir das
diese Prozesse begleiten ich glaube
durch die Etablierung der islamischen
Theologie hier in Deutschland im
europäischen Kontext das wird uns von
der islamischen Welt immer wieder
übrigens auch gesagt hat man eine Chance
innerhalb von demokratischen Strukturen
des Theologie sich ohne eben Angst zu
haben ohne dass da Druck von
außen da ist dass sich die islamische
Theologie entfaltet und das ist unsere
Hoffnung dass der Impulse von hier aus
gehen von Europa auch in die islamische
Welt uns
hat vor einiger Zeit der der der groß
von ahar besucht in Münster eben auch
als Zeichen äh diesen Islam brauchen wir
auch wenn man das in Ägypten vielleicht
so nicht sagen kann einiges das erleben
wir in den Kooperationen in vielen
islamischen Ländern dass uns gesagt wird
wenn wir zu Euch zu Kongressen kommen
können wir uns Dinge erlauben zu sein
die wir sonst so denken die wir aber
dort in unseren Fakultäten so nicht
sagen können ich glaube das ist unsere
Verantwortung diese Räume zu öffnen für
diese wohl wahr nun ist ja aber doch die
die Wahrnehmung der europäischen
Öffentlichkeit mehr auf Kontroversen
aufgelegt die ja publizistisch dann auch
plakatiert werden der Streit um die
Mohammedkarikaturen z.B vor einiger Zeit
hat ja doch gezeigt dass das
Religionsverständnis im ja abendländisch
geprägten Europa völlig anders ist als
es dem muslimischen Verständnis
entspricht kann man das überhaupt
zueinander bringen gibt's da irgendwann
doch mal Barrieren die nicht zu
überwinden sind Herr UG also wir Muslime
sage ich mal wir leben von unserer
Geschichte und zwar wir erinnern uns an
unsere Geschichte sehr selektiv und Z
wir
haben Werke was her josid erwähnt hat
nämlich
von gestorben
1148 das Buch die Heilung if oder bia
auch nämlich
oderki nämlich das sind Werke die
nämlich die Kritik des Propheten einfach
kategorisch vhement ablehnen und jeder
der den Propheten kritisiert muss
hingerichtet werden und die Muslime
betrachten Mohammed als als als eine
Autorität die man einfach nicht
kritisiert heutezutag sie berufen sich
auch auf eine Stelle im Koran das ist
glaube ich die Sure 5 Vers 33 und zwar
er spricht nicht aus aus aus
persönlicher Neigung allerdings hier das
ein Interpretationssache ich tendiere
eher dazu dass der Gott über den Koran R
nun zurück zu ihrer Frage also es ist
unsere Aufgabe nämlich mit dem Propheten
Mohammed auch kritisch umzugehen und
jeder der den Propheten kritisiert
braucht keine Angst um sein Leben und
wir sehen halt dass die Muslime das ist
ein Tabu Thema für Sie dass Mohammed den
Propheten kritisiert aber reden wir noch
mal von diesem europäischen Kontext und
da wir brauchen keine Angst wenn
Mohammed kritisiert wird oder auch mit
Karikaturen es ist es ist einfach der
Diskurs bei uns im Westen wo man ohne
Angst mit solchen sage ich mal
Persönlichkeiten umgeht und dass man sie
in Frage stellt ein Prozess der
Aufklärung in Europa aber der ist ja
noch nicht vollendet warum nicht wir
brauchen wir brauchen Zeit wirklich wir
Muslime wir sind dabei einfach dabei
sage ich mal aufgeklärte Muslime wir
sind dabei einfach diese
Aufklärungsprozess bei uns im Westen zu
etablieren dadurch näm dass wir den die
Menschen auf der Basis dazu ermutigen
dass sie erstmal ihre Geschichte in
Frage stellen dass sie ihre eigene
Religion entdecken das ist die
sogenannte entdeckte Identität im
westlichen Kontext also wir sind dabei
besonders bei unseren Studierenden
einfach nämlich sie sie dazu zu bewegen
dass sie die eigene Identität
reflexieren können und zwar auf eine
kritische Basis alt wir sehen bei
unseren Studierenden wenn wir über
Mohammed als kriegsher reden dann die
Armen Studierende kriegen erstmal einen
Schock weil sie das in den Gemeinden
nicht mal gelernt haben und das ist
unsere Aufgabe sag ich als Vertreter der
islamischen Theologie und der
islamischen Religionspädagogik diese
Aufklärungsprozess voranzutreiben sind
die islamischen Gemeinden in Deutschland
denn so konservativ dass das ein Schock
ist wenn sie solche Dinge hören äh ich
würde nicht pauschalieren äh jede
Gemeinde auch innerhalb der jeweiligen
Gemeinde gibt es solche und solche
Strömungen dazu muss man sein ist es
auch nicht Aufgabe der Gemeinden sich
intellektuell wissenschaftlich mit
diesen Werken auseinanderzusetzen das
ist ja Aufgabe der Theologie und ich
vermisse in der Tat was Frau KEM
angesprochen hat vorher einen
intellektuellen islamisch theologischen
Diskurs also ich sehe vieles plakatives
was gesagt wird vieles pauschales aber
es fehlt noch und an einem
intellektuellen Diskurs und ich hoffe
mir durch die Etablierung dieser
islamischen Zentren des an den
Universitäten diese Diskurs
fortgeführt werden und etabliert werden
die Intellektuellen Diskurse in in der
Auseinandersetzung mit der islamischen
Theologie man soll darf ich das noch
sagen man sollte vielleicht auch die die
Moscheegemeinden nun nicht für die
einzigen Sprecher der Muslimin und
Muslime in diesem Lande halten die
Verbände wir kennen ja doch auch
wahrscheinlich aus persönlicher
Erfahrung eine ganze Reihe von Menschen
gleichgültig welchen Passes die sich als
Muslime verstehen wenn man will als
kulturmuslime die auch da eine gewiss
Identität sehen und die deswegen noch
lange nicht von morgens bis abends über
die islamischen Normen nachdenken oder
sich fragen ob nun Mohammad dies oder
jenes getan hat häufig haben sie da ein
eheres wages wissen also wir sollten
vielleicht auch nicht zu sehr uns
fixieren auf besonders enggherzige
Vertreter des Islams sondern ein
weiteren Blick haben und auf jeden Fall
in der wissenschaftlichen Beschäftigung
uns davon auch nicht immer beengen
lassen denn es kann nicht sein ich setze
mich ja wenn ich über Jesus spreche auch
nicht auseinander mit
irgendwelchen Evangelikalen Kräften bei
denen nun kein Fünkchen des Zweifels
zulässig ist sondern da muss man sich
schon auch drüber hinwegsetzen als
Pädagoge und Theologe in anderer Weise
als ich aber aber zum gewissen Grad muss
man sich drüberin wegsetzen reden wir
doch mal jetzt über die andere Seite die
nichtmuslimische Öffentlichkeit in
Europa in Deutschland in einer aktuellen
Umfrage von Allensbach dieser Tage geben
63% der deutschen an der Islam gehöre
nicht zu Deutschland der Bundespräsident
Wulf hat das ja mal anders gesagt wie
wir wissen woher diese Ablehnung der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit der
nichtmuslimischen Öffentlichkeit der
og also ich bin der Überzeugung dass
diese Frage ob der Islam zu Deutschland
gehört oder nicht gehört das ist ein
veraltete Frage unser wir haben hier
Kinder in der zweiten und dritten
Generation die hier geboren sind und die
fühlen sich in erster Linie als Deutsche
und ich finde sehr schade dass die
Menschen hier sage ich mal mit
Migrationshintergrund auf ihre
Religionszugehörigkeit reduziert zu
werden es ist doch selbstverständlich
dass Menschen hier sage ich mal von von
der Mehrheit Gesellschafts Angst vor dem
Islam haben ja wie unser Alltag zeigt
unds durch die Migration
bedingt na ja auch dieser Tage das war
ja in vor etlichen Wochen diese Umfrage
und die steht natürlich unter dem
Eindruck es ist es ist eher diese Angst
vor diesem politischen Islam halt denn
wir überall inzwischen auch in Europa
erleben Attentate und so weiter also die
Menschen haben Angst vor diesem
politischen Islam aber wir haben auch
wirklich die Mehrheit der Muslime die
hier bei uns leben da sind friedliche
Menschen die möchchen n ihre Ruhe haben
und einfach leben wie andere Menschen es
geht wirklich um ein ein Koexistenz
zwischen den Menschen hier es ist auch
die Aufgabe nämlich der Muslime sich
nicht immer in die diese Opferrolle zu
geraten wo sie ständig sich verteidigen
es ist auch die Aufgabe der
Mehrheitsgesellschaft diese Menschen als
integrale Bestandteil unser Gesellschaft
sind die diese Menschen die zweite
dritte Generation sie sind nicht mehr
weg zu zu sehen andererseits sind dann
doch solche Ereignisse wie diese
Attentate seit dem 11 September jetzt
dieser Tage auch in Brüssel vorher in
Paris Madrid London natürlich da so
angetan um eine solche Ablehnung ein
solches Misstrauen in der europäischen
Öffentlichkeit zu befördern wie wie kann
man damit umgehen was was ist da die die
Idee es ist sehr wichtig die Menschen
aufzuklären dass das nicht der Mehrheit
der Muslime im Gegenteil Muslime sind
genauso von Terror betroffen wie nicht
Muslime denken Sie an is der sten von
Zeh sind das neu Muslime die sten unter
is und genauso diese Terror Europa der
unterscheidet nicht zwischen Muslimen
und Nichtmuslimen das ist erst einmal
wichtig
die Menschen aufzuklären dass man hier
differenziert was auch wichtig ist
die sozialen Maßnahmen die
Länder die sie erwähnt haben Paris
Brüssel
die Jugendlichen die dort sozial
marginalisiert sind die sich dann
leichter rekrutieren lassen in solche
extremistischen Milieus äh da ist die
Frage keine rein theologische Frage
sondern auch eine soziale Frage zugleich
ähm warum fühlen sich diese Menschen
einfach am Rande ihrer Gesellschaft
wieso haben Sie das Gefühl ich habe
nichts zu verlieren ich sterbe Liebe
damit ich das bekomme was ich hier auf
dieser Erde nicht bekomme deshalb ist es
wichtig hier auch soziale Maßnahmen der
Integration dieser Menschen gerade des
sozial benachteiligten einzuführen
soziale Maßnahmen sind das eine aber ist
es nicht auch die Aufgabe etwa der
muslimischen Verbände stärker Flagge zu
zeigen noch stärker zu sagen das ist
nicht unser Weg das das ist nicht unser
glaube das ist nicht unsere Politik
definitiv ist es wichtig dass Signale
aus der muslimischen Seite immer lauter
werden gleichzeitig Signale auch der
Unterstützung von Gegenangebote
also was ich hier mache die Betonung der
humanistischen Werte im Islam der
Barmherzigkeit im Islam da würde ich mir
mehr Unterstützung erwarten als gegen
narrativ gegen diese extremistischen
Strömungen nicht zu sagen wir sind gegen
das aber wir unterstützen nicht das
andere Angebot man braucht alternative
Angebote sich dafür stark machen ich
fand es auch sehr wichtig dass der
großcheich von ashar hier in Deutschland
auch vom Bundestag ganz klare
Worte gesprochen hat wo sich von Gewalt
distanziert hat als Oberhaupt oder
zumindest wichtige Figur in der
islamischen Welt ist wichtig solche
Signale zu senden W sie erlauben ich
möchte gerne in der Frage oder über die
Frage der Dachverbände tchiles reden gut
wir haben hier Dachverbände nämlich
steht über unsco die vertreten erstmal
15% aller lebenden Muslime hier in
Deutschland 15 15 ja also ich frage mich
wo bleibt der Rest halt erstens zweitens
wir haben Dachverbände die vom Ausland
finanziert werden wie die D von dem
religiösen Ministerium da und so weiter
also ich finde sehr schade dass frem
sage ich mal ausländig Regierungen über
die Zukunft der Religion unsere Bürger
im Ausland entscheiden es ist unsere
Aufgabe nämlich diese Dachverbände zu
kritisieren wir können auch auch das
sagen es hat sich bei uns durch durch
die Macht der daverbände in den
Gemeinden ein sehr konservativer Islam
etabliert das spüren wir und deshalb ich
finde sehr schade dass unser Kirchen und
auch die Politiker nämlich ich finde es
toll dass sie mit den dachverbend
zusammenarbeiten aber nur die Frage sind
die Dachverbänden wirklich wie die
Kirchen haben sie die diese diesen
gleichen Weg der Aufklärungsprozess die
die Kirchen durch oder erlebt
haben ich sage nein also das sind
Dachverbände die sind eher interessiert
an Deutungshoheit in religiösen Fragen
und nämlich ihnen geht's in erster Linie
um die Vertretung der Muslime wir sage
ich mal Wissenschaftler wir reden eher
hier nämlich zu reden darüber oder wir
versuchen einfach ein ein aufgek Islam
hier zu etablieren und wir brauchen
wirklich nicht Vertreter also der Islam
es ist nicht der Christentum wir haben
keine Autorität Autorität halt die in
Rom sitzt oder irgendwo Halt der Islam
es ist eher ein individuelles
resonierung resonieren dass ist eine
spirituelle Bindung zwischen Gott und
dem Einzelnen in erster Linie also wenn
diese Sendung eine Botschaft hätte dann
würde sie ja heißen der
Aufklärungsprozess muss sich mal zu
allererst auf die Dachverbände des Islam
in Deutschland erstrecken Frau Krämer
ach ich würde mich da jetzt auch nicht
in erster Linie abarbeiten ich halte es
für absolut wichtig dass Muslimin und
Muslime die eine andere Auffassung von
Islam vertreten sie auch leben in die
Öffentlichkeit rücken und wahrgenommen
werden als
Selbstverständlichkeit als normales
Faktum als Glied dieser
Gesellschaft die müssen ja auch nicht
immer zu theologisch sprechen sie können
ja in unterschiedlichsten Berufs Gruppen
sein und ich glaube in dem Moment wo wir
diese Normalisierung haben wo man nicht
aufhcht weil die Nachrichtensprecherin
eische heißt oder der
ähm Physiker
Mohammad hat sich schon viel getan und
die können ja dann auch durch ihr Leben
und durch ihre Äußerung etwas dazu
beitragen dass ich dieses Bild lockert
dass militante Islamisten den wahren
Islam vertreten oder viel mehr den Islam
wie er wirklich ist wenn man den Koran
richtig verstanden hat so lautet ja das
Argument häuf weil sie das selber
behaupten und andere das dankbar
aufnehmen oder auf jeden Fall
aufnehmen also ich denke die
Dachverbände soll man nicht
verabsolutieren
es müssen andere Musliminnen und Muslime
in der Öffentlichkeit präsent sein in
unterschiedlichen Bereichen dann kann
man hoffen das ist ein langsamer Prozess
aber gerade in den Medien haben sie da
ja durchaus eine wichtige Rolle zu
spielen sie können das ja mitgestalten
ich denke das tun wir weit gehen
jedenfalls Herr kchit ich würde gehen
das unter äh streichen was Frau Kremmer
gesagt hat
weil alles nur jetzt den Verbänden
zuzuschieben zu sein sie sind Schulen
die müssen sich aufklären überhaupt die
Frage der Aufklärung da finde ich sehr
wichtig hier dass Muslimen ermöglicht
wird ihren eigenen Weg der Aufklärung zu
gehen also sze wie die Kirchen haben das
gemacht die Verbände nicht das sind ja
andere Prozesse auch eben wir haben ja
keine Kirche in dem Sinn das heißt es
muss eine innerislamische Aufklärung
stattfinden aber die Muslime müssten ja
definieren was meinen wir mit Aufklärung
was meinen wir mit Reform wenn wir das
sagen man darf nicht europäische
Konzepte einfach nur übernehmen und
sagen jetzt setzen wir das auf den Islam
auf sondern jede Kultur jede Religion
muss auch ihren eigenen Weg gehen und
das ist mir auch wichtig und wie sie
gesagt haben sind ja lange nicht jetzt
die Verbände alleine sondern was wir
brauchen ist einen Diskurs wo möglichst
viele Muslime auch erreicht werden aber
auch viele der Mehrheitsgesellschaft
erreicht werden äh eine friedlichen
Koexistenz wo Religion eine positive
Rolle hier spielt und ihre positive
Energie entfalten kann und nicht als
hindnis kann das aber letzten Endes dann
nur eine pluralistische Entwicklung sein
also ein europäischer Islam eine ganz
andere Perspektive als der Islam in
Saudi-Arabien das kann man ja gar nicht
zusammenführen wenn das geschehen soll
was sie erstreben Herr i also ein Islam
in der Singularform gibt's nicht es gibt
ein Islam nur in den kanonischen Quell
Quellen Koran und sun wir haben Muslime
aller couure Rechtsschulen besonders und
verschiedene Rechtsschulen verschiedene
Muslime aus verschiedenen Länder hier
das ist sage ich mal eine eine ein
fundierte Basis bei uns in dem Westen
nämlich einen toleranten Islam zu
etablieren ein Islam der sich in erster
Linie respektiert und den anderen auch
respektiert wie Leben mit dem anderen
wie sind wir hier Muslime in der
Minderheit und es ist für uns ein
Bereicherung von anderen was zu lernen
in der islamischen Theologie und
religionspädagog müssen zusammen mit den
christlichen und juddischen
religionspädagog und Theologie
zusammenarbeiten wir müssen von dem
anderen lernen und nur dadurch kehren
wir zurück zu unser eigene Identität
durch diese Berührung mit dem anderen
also ich werde ich werde nicht meine
Identität verlieren wenn ich jetzt mich
beschäftige mit anderen Diskurs das ist
das allerwichtigste für diese sage ich
mal das diskursive friedliches Leben
miteinander ist ein Element dieser
erstrebenswerten Aufklärung nicht auch
dass man in Sachen Muhammed um mal
wieder zurückzukehren zum eigentlichen
Thema gar nicht aufhören darf mehr
wissen zu wollen sonst müssten wir ja
irgendwann mal nur glauben und sonst
nichts also ich denke die die das
kritische nachdenken ist wichtig wiss
mehr Wissen per se führt ja nicht
unbedingt zu einem aufgeklärteren
Verständnis es kann ja auch sein dass
man so und so viele Dinge erfährt die
nun in eine andere Richtung weisen also
das schiere wissen als solches bringt es
noch nicht um es so zu sagen sondern es
geht tatsächlich darum dass alle äh mit
diesem kritischen auch selbstkritischen
Blick umgehen aber das betrifft auch
diejenen die kritisch auf den Islam
schauen dass sie eben auch aufgerufen
sind nicht nur bestimmte Stimmen
wahrzunehmen sondern die anderen ebenso
und sich selber auch in Frage zu stellen
in dem eigenen Bild der eigenen
kulturellen Identität der eigenen
Religion Europa als christliches Land
das immer nur der Toleranz und
Aufklärung verpflichtet war das ist ja
auch ein Mythos ne also man kann gerade
diese Auseinandersetzung zum Anlass
nehmen da kritisch nachzudenken und dann
vor allem hinzuhören das klingt ein
bisschen Pastoral aber das fehlt häufig
dass man dem anderen überhaupt zuhört
und stimmen wahrnimmt die da sind und
die aber anders klingen als das was uns
z.B aus dem Irak entgegenschalt zum
Abschluss eine Frage wie sie für Sie die
Forschung die Zukunft der historischen
mohammadforschung aus welchen Fokus
würden Sie sich wünschen ich würde mir
mehr kritisches Denken wünschen ohne
Angst zu haben allgemein in der
Forschung gerade W wenn es um Religion
geht gerade wenn es um Mohammed oder um
den Koran geht dass wir Muslime auch mit
mehr Mut auch kritische Forschung
zulassen im Sinne der Religion selbst
kritische Forschung bedeutet nicht eine
Deformierung der Religion genau das
Gegenteil
dass man nicht einfach unhinterfragt
undrelektiert Dinge übernimmt sondern
sie genauer durchdacht
und und und durchforscht Herri also ich
sage immer diesen Satz und das ist einer
meinen Grundprinzipien im Leben Kritik
ist ein Liebeserklärung wir leben wir
lieben den Islam und sie respektieren
die Muslime es ist unsere Aufgabe
nämlich kritisch mit unserer Geschichte
und um äh umzugehen es ist unsere
Aufgabe das dynamische historische
verdrängen in unserer Geschichte einfach
beiseite zu lassen Frau gremmer last
words ich habe dem gar nicht viel
hinzuzufügen
ich würde denken am wichtigsten wer sich
mit ist mit Mohammad Bildern und Islam
Bildern und deren Umsetzung im eigenen
Leben in späteren Zeiten bisschen unsere
Gegenwart auseinanderzusetzen ich
persönlich würde gar nicht mehr so viel
Zeit verwenden auf die Erforschung
Einzel Quellen zum historischen Mohammad
das sind aber Präferenzen ich habe nur
einen anderen Schwerpunkt und denke für
unsere gesellschaftliche Diskussion
heute wäre es wichtig mit diesen Bildern
und deren Umsetzung im eigenen Leben
sich zu beschäftigen und zwar mit dieser
durchaus von einer gewissen Sympathie
getragenen empathischen kritischen
Grundhaltung voila der Prophet der
Aufklärung Voltaire hat ja mal gesagt
geschichte ist die Lüge auf die man sich
geeinigt hat sehen Sie wohin es führt
wenn man die Aufklärung betreiben will
ihnen dreien danke ich für ihre
interessanten Aussagen und Ihnen liebe
Zuschauer danke ich für ihr Interesse
bleiben sie uns
[Musik]
treu